this video is sponsored by ridgewatt
i've just finished reading whole cake
island and boy do i have a lot of
thoughts to voice about this wild and
wonderful tale that has
pushed sanji up a few wrongs in my
favorite straw hats list
last week i covered the beginning of
this arc but this week i will be looking
at
everything else as well as assessing the
ark's overall presentation
and story as a whole i'm gonna be honest
i haven't slept in about three days
thanks to this little guy but i'll be
damned if anything stops me from
reviewing one piece today i want to try
and explain my thoughts concerning whole
cake island as
a whole discussing this impressive and
complex story one piece has taken me on
from its visuals to its dialogue
to its story structure i'm totally not
mark and these are my first impressions
of
thoughts on and review for the scary the
chaotic
and the satisfying whole cake island
so whole cake island is pretty long and
great
it's almost 80 chapters in length and
spans nine volumes of my now comically
large
collection of one-piece manga and over
the course of the last
wow it's been almost five months i've
been in what i think to be a unique
position where my job allowed me to
intake
the entire series of one piece in what
is comparatively a short amount of time
considering the story has been in the
process of being told for almost a
quarter century
and so during my time reading through
the life's work of hero oda i've noticed
a considerable amount of passion in how
he likes to write but
also his approaches to drawing manga has
changed too over his career
and i think whole cake island helped me
get a firmer grip of what it is i love
about one piece categorically
and what it is that frustrated me about
it too now i want to preface this by
saying that i still
love this story and i think it ranks up
there as one of the best one-piece
sections
easily and while i think it's somewhat
funny that whole cake island being one
of my personal favorites in the series
is also one that helped me see what i
think is a flaw and so in this video i
will explain why this wonderful arc
helped me put my finger on what it is
about one piece
that might have prevented it from in my
humble opinion being even better
however before i get into anything
regarding my opinions i should also say
that i've been exposed to very limited
amounts of the animes material outside
of a few clips my friends have
hand-picked to share with me
for the purpose of this review so all my
opinions have been formulated from my
exposure with the manga exclusively
now i understand what it feels like to
hear things that you might not
necessarily want to hear or agree with
in addition to that to smooth over the
very small amount of negativity i have
in this video
i have supplied my editor with plenty of
pictures of my new 10 week old puppy
called teddy
to feature in this video anytime i
criticize this wonderful story so let's
get all the great stuff out of the way
first one of the very first things that
stood out to me as interesting about
this arc as i was reading
was how it was structured unlike the
vast majority of one piece of stories
that are tied together by one
establishing main plot thread that holds
the focus from beginning to the finish
this story can be perfectly split into
two distinct parts that my friends
thankfully advised me to cover in
separate videos
obviously the crew leave with the
objective of meeting up with and taking
back sanji but by the time my last
review
ended the motivation for the straw hats
had changed completely due to the events
of that story
this not only felt like a natural
extension of it but also helped with the
pacing tremendously we don't have to get
through almost 80 chapters of story to
get sanji back onto the squad that
mission objective is achieved not even
halfways through with the first half
also laying the groundwork in characters
like big mom's hunger pangs pudding's
powers and the wedding ceremony proper
to name but a few that play pivotal
roles in the second half of this tale
constantly in the second half it feels
like we're going from one major moment
to the next full of interesting
opportunities for these characters to
participate in and
interact with with two clear standout
scenes early on coming from luffy's
meeting with beji
that contained a few pages a little more
explicit than i'm comfortable with while
sitting around my fiance
and of course the big moment that was
established in the prior arcs of the
story
the wedding of sanji and pudding in fact
by the way something funny that i
noticed
on the cover of volume 86 we get a nice
image of pudding and sanji about to be
wet
note the eye contact and height
difference now
if you skip to chapter 862 you'll find
that corresponding artwork for this
volume itself with sanji instead of
looking into her eyes like the cover it
looks like he's looking at her boobs
even in moments of extreme stress he's
unable to restrain himself
classic but again this second half of
the story feels like it could be
categorized as its own arc
in the same way that water 7 and his
lobby were part of the same story threat
i understand one piece likes to name its
axe by the name of islands visited but
i mean they could have called it cacao
island or something i don't know
the meeting with benji is honestly
mostly for exposition and a bit of humor
with large amounts of the appeal coming
from luffy's interactions with beijing
himself and steve
who finds himself in capone's possession
which as it happens is a good thing
because he ends up playing a vital role
once again in the arc early concerning
the plan to crash sanji's wedding and to
foil their plans
however what i thought was interesting
concerning this portion of the story is
that luffy
indirectly becomes involved in a plan to
assassinate big mom
now that plan does involve aspects of
the big mom character we weren't privy
to prior to this plan
coming to light and so it feels more
like exposition rather than the reveal
of the plan first and foremost
a significant amount of focus regarding
this plan concerns the picture frame big
mom cherishes that acts also as the
impetus for one of the only flashbacks
proper in this part of the story
personally i didn't anticipate nor
think that big mom required a backstory
but now that we have one i suppose
i did enjoy certain parts from it and
after all whitebeard got one too and the
sections that i really enjoyed were
those that explored elbaf for the very
first time this was a place that we had
heard about during little garden and is
now a place we've finally seen
albeit in the distant past there's also
this rather
gruesome scene or at least i think it's
gruesome scene where we see a young big
mom devour a cake but also her entire
group of friends
and mother carmel i appreciate in some
respects the painting oda is trying to
capture for us in this flashback an
orphan that was never understood and
always put down
it's clear that big mom is misguided and
began with the best of intentions but
when we flash forward to the president
and see big mom hacking and slashing her
way through town after town after town
presumably killing people
including her own children by the way
i'm not sure if that flashback could be
as effective for me considering the
heinous act she's continuing to perform
even when not
under the trends of her hunger pang now
i do appreciate that it stands to make
her a slightly more nuanced than perhaps
a more interesting character taking the
if you were all judged on our worst day
that how good would any of us be sort of
approach but if your character has more
bad days than one can count and
is a literal tyrant it falls short in
making me gain sympathy for her in a lot
of respects
that is assuming that's what oda wanted
to do he might not have one of the most
hotly anticipated scenes from this
portion of the ark for me was the doomed
wedding of sanji and pudding
which totally lived up to the hype for
me by the way despite it acting as an
assassination attempt by both big mom's
forces and veggie
it has an enjoyable amount of sustained
tension with the countdown to the moment
it all goes down on it has some striking
visuals as i mentioned a crazy backstory
and more than enough comedy to add some
variety to stop the occasion from
getting a little too straightforward and
the best part is that like most plans
made in one piece
they don't go according to plan because
let's be honest
that'd be boring and i think in having
things go awry from the get-go not only
did it make for a much more interesting
and fleshed out occasion with the
wedding itself but it also
served to create a set of circumstances
afterwards that produce one of the
single best fight scenes i've seen in
the series as well as the foundations
for a structure that i found to be both
easy to understand
and exciting and there are numerous
highlights from this wedding from the
tense build-up to the planned enactment
to the sweet and tender moments shared
by sanji and pudding and of course the
hundreds of luffys exploding out of the
wedding cake
destroying it which as funny as it was
turns out to be one of the main missteps
in this arc because
big mom she'd be wanting some wedding
cake and she's gonna be saying that a
lot from this point on something else i
thought was worth mentioning was
something a friend of mine pointed out
to me once i encountered putting in the
story
apparently she was featured in chapter
651
that is hundreds of chapters ago which
again reinforces the notion that oda is
an absolute lunatic when it comes to
foreshadowing events in his story
and while we're on the topic of pudding
i have to say she really surprised me as
a character
while i wasn't super interested in her
goody two-shoes persona that was
presented to us early on
once it was revealed that she was just
evil the entire time i
wasn't really expecting anything too
interesting to come from her thereafter
but boy was i wrong once she
legitimately starts to fall for sanji
after he calls her third eye beautiful
the mental gymnastics this woman
performs in order to attempt to speak
and
rationalize with was one of the funniest
and most charming parts of this
arc for me with her also playing a
pivotal role in the side of good within
this part of the story
she's easily one of my favorite
characters introduced in any of the
islands we've visited since the
beginning
something that also came to my attention
during my time reading this was
how strange it must have felt reading
week to week for a lot of people
being exposed to only one half of the
straw hat crew at any given time
splitting them up in dressrosa and once
again in whole cake i'm
actively aware that i'm in a rather
unique position where i can dedicate
half of this year to catching up on this
series and as a result i
bulldozed through it i was only reading
the style of dress rosa a few weeks ago
but for some of you watching this you
must have gone
years without seeing some of these
characters you've grown up with and i
wonder what that must have been like
in saying that i thought punk hazard
suffered from having too many characters
and i definitely think splitting the
crew into a more focused group was a
good idea
but i bet there were a lot of you out
there that were during this time missing
zorro for the two years oda spent on
whole cake island i suppose i'll get an
idea of what that might be like as i get
caught up to this series later this year
back to the wedding however there's a
rather awesome set of circumstances that
sanji shares with his family and more
specifically
his father who when faced with the truth
of the occasion breaks down
into tears a broken man and while
sanji's relationship with his father and
brothers doesn't come to the forefront
again after the first half of this arc
it gets a bunch of noteworthy instances
where either sanji is a hero for wanting
to save his family where they actively
provide sanji and the straw hats cover
in trying to escape the wedding and
later on in the high seas within big
mom's territory but
most importantly to me was the decision
oda made to not have
sanji forgive his father for them not to
make amends and for him to stay firmly
in the corner of zeth these are
incredibly complicated emotions to be
explored as a piece of side dressing in
this arc and i thought it was both
hugely enjoyable and fit perfectly in
that position the clear highlight
however from this wedding for me was the
scene where jinbe officially resigns his
allegiance to big mom
on top of it already having terrific
tension due to the risk factors involved
with asking this of big mom
what's interesting actually about this
is that we get a greater insight into
how big mom's powers actually
work and that is they only work if
you're scared and because jinbei doesn't
fear her
he gets one of the most badass lines
i've heard certainly from his character
and maybe even the entire series as he
hands back his sake up he says
a man who will become a crewmate to the
future king of the pirates cannot afford
to tremble in the face
of a mere emperor
i don't need a senzu for that one
despite the rest of this wedding
aftermath contributing hugely to my
enjoyment of the ark the rest of the
story is where i think it shines
brightest
certainly in the chase scene section
that promotes a ton of interesting
offensive and defensive techniques in
tandem with a plot thread that splinters
in the most fun way i could think of and
while i think the emotional highs were
observed in the first half of the story
that i covered last week
the tension and the action is at its
highest in this part
thankfully one of the reasons i love how
this entire story expands and progresses
is largely due to a concept in art which
is called
context drives form it's a simple idea
and what that means in a nutshell is
that the events from the past inform
and help design the outcomes later in
other words the wedding goes bad
therefore
big mom chases the straw hats therefore
her forces attack the straw hats
therefore luffy is forced to improvise
and overcome everything works as a
building block informed from the prior
events
and this is just one example of how and
why the plot works and flows so well
in this portion of the manga for me
however it's not without something i
took issue with you see there's a
specific callback to the bomb luffy
accidentally sent to big mom
in a box now when this was set up way
back at the end of fishman island
i was very excited this is quite
literally alfred hitchcock's bomb under
the table analogy in action across a
detailed and sprawling world
simply put if you put a bomb under the
table and say it's going to go off
there's a tension that's established
between the story
and its audience and ever since that
bomb was put in motion i had anticipated
it showing up at any moment
coating the pages of every interaction
with big mom was a palpable tension
concerning when the bomb might show up
and go off i was certain that it might
inform an action by big mom towards
luffy or perhaps it might even show up
and the straw hats might leverage it for
their own game
but none of this happens however instead
the straw hats for the first time that i
can think of were literally beaten and
about to lose without
any options this is when through sheer
coincidence
in circumstances surrounding the bomb's
explosion it indirectly saved the straw
hat crew to me that is extremely
convenient and slightly disappointing
considering it was something that was
left lying there in the back of my mind
for so so long but then again i suppose
not nearly as long as it was for all of
you with that said however it's not a
big deal and the arc picks right back up
from that point and right up until the
very end and while this section of the
story does concern a certain donut
loving strong boy called katakuri what i
am most pleased with this section for is
his dedication to giving the other
members of the crew
tremendous utility because the plan was
to get in and get out not to get into
conflict with big mom was imperative and
so luffy is reminded that the priority
is to escape i mean they don't even have
zoro one of their best fighters presents
so it only makes sense and i really like
how this r2 expresses interest in making
sure it wasn't another one of those arcs
where they mosey on
up to a new town and defeat their
strongest before ascending the pecking
order yet again these specific
circumstances will require strategy and
preparation
certainly not something they can all
just dive into flying by the seat of
their pants despite luffy really wanting
to at times clearly
specifically during this midpoint of
this section where big mom relentlessly
chases them down across her territory
now in a panicked mindless frenzy thanks
to her hunger pangs she becomes a
real force of nature to contend with
this section specifically climb actually
with a wonderfully clever and visually
impressive lightning shock from nami
to big mom utilizing her own strengths
in zeus against her however
during this chase scene i was beginning
to get a little worried for one specific
reason
and that's big mom while in this date
she presents a very impressive and
frankly scary force to oppose and
threaten the straw hats with she
is also not nearly as interesting while
she is in the state
rarely stringing together more than two
words outside the realm of wedding and
or
cake because she wants the wedding cake
luffy destroyed
she loses all of her personality and
ability to talk in any sort of
introspective way with other characters
this is why all she does in this arc is
chase and fight which on its own did
provide some incredible moments like
when she was attacking the sunny or
more specifically when pedro who gave up
his life in a scene that was honestly
way more emotional than i was expecting
having only just met this character a
single arc ago
coupled with some illuminating flashback
sequences picturing roger and a young
pedro together
it was a really tragic set of scenes
that really i wasn't prepared for
and thankfully this fantastic pacing
continues despite the absence of a
personality driven big mom and that's
largely thanks to a number of characters
the most popular of which being the
coolest middle-aged man to ever live
with his own mother the second
son of big mom with a bounty of over 1
billion it's katakuri
so what are we waiting for let's get my
thoughts on what i might consider one of
the best fights in the series luffy
versus katakuri
this video is brought to you by ridge
wallet most people are still using
wallets designed in the 1990s and in
this modern landscape it's seriously
outdated
and i should know i've been using the
same wallet since i was 15 years old and
that means i've been using some outdated
wallet for the last
14 years of my life in the same way
phones have gotten more practical and
compact over the last few decades so too
of wallets and
it's honestly made a massive difference
to my pockets personally i hate having
cumbersome items in there and this
totally fits my new lifestyle it holds
up to 12 separate cards plus room for
cash and there's over 30 different
colors and styles including carbon fiber
and burnt titanium to choose from
and if that wasn't enough to win you
over yet check out their thirty thousand
five star reviews the durable nature of
each of these wallets comes with a
lifetime warranty so
in theory you could buy this one wallet
and carry it for life and the rich team
have told me that they're so confident
that you like it that they'll actually
let you test drive it for 45 days that
means you can send it back for a full
refund if it's not up to your own
standards
right now there's a special offer going
where you can get 10 off with
free worldwide shipping and returns and
you can get all of this by going to
ridge.com
not mark and using the coupon code not
mark at checkout
link is in the description
[Music]
one of the many aspects that made this
as great as it was for me was
its setup despite being introduced as
katakuri earlier in the arc i still
didn't really understand much about him
beyond one very interesting aspect and
that being his mastery of
the color of observation haki to such an
extent that he can actually see into the
future and really it's this a tribute to
his character
as well as his stoic demeanor that puts
him on a pedestal above the rest of
those around him he's very much
respected by everyone around him and
like the rest of the big mom pirates
wants to stop them in their tracks so as
not to ruin the reputation of big mom as
an emperor now obviously it's wonderful
when motivations line up but at this
moment in time i'm by no means under any
illusion that he's
a particularly deep character but he
works well for what this arc currently
needs
a capable no-nonsense powerhouse to
bolster the ranks of big mom while also
offering luffy
an antagonist to joust with both
physically and verbally however
while i will say that he's not super
interesting emotionally to me i will
admit he's much more than meets the eye
on first viewing with one of the very
first orders he gives to the crew being
that of
retreat having seen the future and
recognizing that they do not need to lay
down their bodies
here in the face of the straw hats this
action also acts as a nice subtle
indication that he isn't some heartless
killing machine either that genuinely
cares for his people
certainly not something you would see
the vast majority of one piece
antagonist ordering and these are just
the building blocks really to the setup
which i think stands as the best start
to a fight in this series for me
bart none having been relentlessly
pursued by katakuri and with his crew on
the verge of defeat
luffy makes the ultimate save by
grabbing him and dragging him into a
mirror dimension with him throwing him
to the side and shattering the mirror
behind him luffy will not leave
anyone hurt his crew and so he's forced
katakuri to contend with him
luffy may be trapped in there with
katakuri but he's also
trapped in there with luffy it's a
wonderful opener in the bout and that's
honestly served well in equal part by
the opening and the environment of the
mirror dimension
used as an arena where they can clash as
much as they want coupled with the odd
instance here and there
where we get to learn a little bit more
about katakuri as a character not being
the awesome cool guy ever
thought he was this fight offers tons in
the way of entertainment lore and
connecting threads as this story races
towards its conclusion
utilizing broken shards of mirror to act
as communicators
very short flashbacks concerning
rayleigh and luffy's training and
comedic moments to demonstrate
katakuri's humanity
culminating with a finish that is
perfectly fitted for a contest between
an individual that can see into the
future and one that is currently
learning to with luffy exclaiming that
he will be the person who becomes the
pirate king and katakuri remarking
before falling
that luffy is looking very far into the
future indeed
it's a great piece of dialogue and
finished beautifully by luffy placing
his hat over the jaw of
katakuri i love this fight and it
offered me my very first lesson on
advanced hockey in the series
and really it's this section of the
story that was my favorite throughout
all of whole cake i think coupled with
sanji's escapades with pudding and the
rest of the straw hats as they tried to
duck and dodge the forces of big mom
in might i add in some incredibly
impressive and captivating ways
i'm serious and it might sound like i'm
always complimenting the action here
and i don't normally do that but i
really thought this arc hit the nail on
the head when it came to fight scenes in
one piece better than dressrosa and
pretty much
every other arc in my opinion heck i
might even categorize the struggle the
forces of jinbe
chopper karen nami and brook undertake
against the forces of big mom
might actually be another one of the
best fights in the series
with brook in particular acting as the
kryptonite to much of big mom's soul
soul fruit ability in other words
brooks a boss in this arc easily his
best showing in anything i've seen so
far from him and so with all of these
three plot lines converging in a perfect
moment that encapsulates the main
throughline of this arc with luffy and
sanji
sanji electing to have unwavering trust
in his captain luffy despite the odds
unlike him trying to deal with it all
himself like he tried to do earlier in
the story oh and by the way before i
forget i really enjoyed what they did
with sanji specifically in this arc they
gave him something to really contend
with morally and ethically which for a
character like him that always wants to
try to do right by everybody male or
female whether he admits it or not it's
a beautiful thing to see unfold as the
story progresses
i'm honestly thrilled with how oda
handled the conflict with his family and
i'm genuinely surprised with how elegant
he handled the father-son dynamic that
colored the vast majority of this story
i've been on something of a
rollercoaster of emotions with this
curly eyebrow blonde kicking chef
in sanji but to tell you the truth he's
really been one of the most
consistently engaging and fun characters
to watch trevors is seen with
and in the same way arlen park served to
make nami a more complex and interesting
character i sincerely believe whole cake
island did exactly that for sanji and
i'm genuinely
happy about that that coupled with the
shocking visuals of big mom as she
shrinks into a more
imposing skinnier version of herself in
pursuit of the cake
is both haunting and awesome in short
this arc made for an exceptionally well
thought out chase sequence rescue and
escape story now as many of you might be
wondering
if i have all of those positive things
to say about this arc and with it being
one of my favorite stories from the
series so far
how on earth could it be that there is
something about this that frustrates me
more than anything else in the series
well in short the more you like
something the more it has a chance to
frustrate and disappoint you the last
chapter of this arc is chapter 902
and i honestly think it's one of the
best chapters from one piece in the
post-time skip material it doesn't do
anything amazing mind you it's heartfelt
and in places quite funny but so what a
lot of one piece is like that in fact
most of it is
and i agree completely with those
arguments but when i see this chapter i
honestly got a little frustrated because
its paneling is fantastic every single
page is clear
easy to read and above all else composed
beautifully
and creatively with instances like
pudding's kiss to sanji being
illustrated like a film reel this is
exactly like how oda drew and structured
his pages back in the early days of one
piece
and it was this reading of this art
coupled with a conversation i had with
another fan of the series that informed
me
that if oda were to structure his
stories like this
consistently which he has shown that he
can do with these modern
arcs we wouldn't be nearly as far into
the story as we would be
which to me isn't a reason not to do it
personally as a fan i can understand why
oda wouldn't want to do it
professionally but for me as a fan
it really disappoints me which might
explain why some people like the animes
adaptation more than the manga
if all you're trying to do is cramming
your chapters with tiny panels in an
effort to get as much story completed as
possible
while you are delivering more story
technically you are crushing the quality
of the way you are telling that story
one criminal offense in this act that i
noticed was that i'm jinbe's retirement
from big mom's pirates
this should have been a large panel
front and center on the page but instead
it was surrounded by tiny panels all in
an effort to get as much of the story
across as possible in a short a span of
time in saying this i know that this
doesn't bother everyone and it might not
even bother a lot of you and i can
totally understand that oda doesn't want
to do this for the rest of his life but
it still irks me to know that oda can
produce beautifully elegant and
well-structured panels but still
chooses not to do in an effort to cram
as much story in as possible this is
like someone speed reading a bedtime
story to you as a kid
sure you get more story but it's not
nearly as engaging or enjoyable at least
not for me
and the very fact that one piece is as
impossibly engaging and amazing as it is
while in my opinion not telling the
story as well as it could be is both a
strange thing to come and realize but
also for me a little frustrating i still
love one piece but this is i think a
valid criticism i totally respect if you
love it purely for the story but for me
manga is a visual medium as much as it
is a written one and the visuals are
just as important
to me as the story i want it also to be
understood that while i have bulldozed
my way through this series with the same
reckless abandoned luffy did when
storming the gates of annie's lobby i
haven't lost sight of the fact that this
is a story almost a quarter century in
the making and whether or not i like
oda's choices for his modern panel
structure doesn't matter i still love
all of these characters i still love
this series and i am thrilled that i
will catch up to it
before it hits the tremendous milestone
of 1 000 chapters soon i hope to see you
all there at the summit
but that'll do it for this phenomenally
well-written whole cake island
now initially i had planned uncovering
reverie as well as the first act of wano
next week
but my friend group that's helped me
with this entire series has advised me
strongly to give reverie its own video
and
given that it's only six chapters long
i'm curious to see why that is
but until then i've been totally not
mark i'll see you all in the next video
and thank you so much for watching
you